6 23 here on a Tuesday Morning a local
non-profit seeks to empower girls of all
ages by building self-esteem but now
it's looking for a new home it's been
displaced we're talking about Emma's
house and the founder shumika green is
here this morning to talk about the
mission and the effort here Shamika good
to meet you this morning appreciate it
thank you thank you for having me I feel
like your co-host today oh you're more
than welcome to you know Heather's not
here so you're more than welcome to help
out
let's talk about what Emma's house is
where folks maybe don't know okay so
is a non-profit that's based here in Las
Vegas but we provide empowerment
programs for girls from elementary all
the way to high school and then we also
have programs for women as well we
provide Therapy Services the biggest
thing is that Emma's house is a safe
space we are the voice for the voiceless
the challenge of of that empowerment
what is the the need in the community
that you see for for young girls in the
valley who need that help who need that
assistance well the biggest thing is is
for example like one of our programs the
beauty from ashes is For Children of
incarcerated parents they need that safe
space they need a place where they can
learn coping skills and learn how to
communicate and know that they have that
support Emma's house plants that seed
for the children and for women and so I
always say that we Empire Empower girls
and Inspire women and of course Emma's
house comes from just a great deal your
own experience as in your past yeah so I
call it the trauma to Triumph story
because when I was growing up in Detroit
I dealt with a lot of trauma my father
was brutally murdered when I was two and
then my mother went to prison when I was
seven and so my life was just it was
very chaotic due to the trauma and the
grief and the loss but it is a beauty
from Ash's story because here I am now
as a licensed marriage and family
therapist trauma specialist grief
specialist and then also the founder of
Emma's house and stuff I you know I turn
my pain into purpose and I imagine when
you're out in the community talking to
girls who are maybe in a traumatic
situation as you're describing
having that person to relate to really
goes a long way yeah it's it's I always
say textbook is like the foundation but
life experience is the teacher and so if
they can look at someone and know that I
was able to really identify or walk in
their shoes it makes a big difference
but then also that you can rewrite your
story like
that's that's that's my story story's
never finished let's talk about the
story you're trying to do now the house
of love campaign right now you're kind
of based out of your garage
what do you need yes so I'm evicting
myself from my house but we need a space
we need a building during the pandemic
we were displaced we made all the
programs virtual which was great at the
time because we were able to meet the
needs but now we need to get into what
looks like a new normal and so we need a
building and so we need donations so we
can be able to provide the kids a safe
stable place to be and they can do that
online yes so on our website
www.emishouseinc.org and you'll see the
house of love campaign it's very good to
meet you good luck in the campaign and
you do great work in the community
appreciate thank you so much of course